vient d'avoir une idée je vais demander
aux gens sur twitter et sur facebook du
raja écoutez on cherchait un gage pour
jean michel maire
non non pas ça jean michel lemaire est
ce que vous pouvez
dans un instant vous irez dans la rue en
slip avec le tee shirt de thierry moreau
qui est vraiment dégueulasse
1 et vous allez essayer d'être pris en
stop d'accord
et vous à la balle et vous allez avoir
une peau carte pour remercier ce lourd
d'emmanuel maubert avec envie de baisser
je suis je suis sûr plein cyril alors
essayez de vous faire prendre poursuit
sera large à la balance à une voiture
s'approche nous a plaidé
c'est quelqu'un ça longtemps dans ce
pôle média quelqu'un qui s'arrête là
qu'elle a dit ça les brouillages un bon
jour je vais vers jean paul rault survie
plaisir à montpellier en plus c'est
génial c'est tout
non je déconne on doit d'être reporté au
20 décembre ressortait fin c'était trop
facile à bâle et camille sée partie pas
dû se faire un petit à petit crochet
feinte de jean michel maire jean michel
berger qui est dans la rue jean michel
berrit dès aujourd'hui c'est le maire
qui est pas faire donc du stop son appel
il doit la béziers jean michel maire
c'est son regard des mois son regard
avec le micro aux biches
bonjour comment vous appelez ça mien un
samia samia ça fait longtemps je suis
pas parti en vacances j'ai une très
grosse envie de béziers est pas très
jaloux je monte je mangeais mon attente
coffre commencer un coffre au nom non
derrière j'avais dit que c'est bien vous
êtes bien aller cette partie dirais que
son héros
le mec je n'ai qu'à pas trop parce que
c'est quand même pas je n'ai pas senti à
fond sur jean michel bergue quand même à
aller mais il est vraiment parti de
guerrier il est tout content le gars
quoi et le gars il est dans une voiture
et tout compte ameli vraiment à l'islam
est sacrée c'est la première fois qu'ils
montent dans une note jean michel bergue
commence à flipper vraiment je vous jure
que c'est vrai alors décédé
ils ont l'air très sympa mais ces genres
gars très sympa fois on a pu la
naissance on n'a plus la maison je suis
très attaché à la mêlée ou vers les
partis très loin ça va mais regardez il
est super mais je suis très inquiet
aujourd'hui c'est le maire jean michel
vous m'entendez nom est longue
oui je vous entends moi mais là je
commence à flipper un peu j'en étais de
maladie
[ __ ] on va la demande évidemment débit
je commence à flipper là mais ouais ce
combat là monsieur habib habibou dit
convaincu jean michel faudra pas tomber
chez les fous j'avais la radio à 21h on
croire à de nouvelles un jour ça lui oui
mais avec enora oui je sais oui
ensuite ce soir avec les pêcheurs de
thierry bon je veux juste reprendre deux
secondes des idéaux jean-michel mais
regardez où super pouvoirs non mais
attendez encore de la voiture bon mais
attendez et bah écoutez on ne sait pas
ce qui va arriver avec jean michel maire
mais on est plutôt confiant merci
louis bertignac était pas
jean michel bérard
ça
à